it's been another tragic week for US
military aviation five service members
have died and the accidents are
continuing national security
correspondent Jennifer Griffin is at the
Pentagon with the fallout could even
Jennifer
good evening Brett late today the Air
Force identified the pilot killed in
yesterday's f-16 crash outside Las Vegas
Maj Steven del baño flew for the elites
Thunderbirds had more than 3500 flying
hours in 30 different types of planes he
was very experienced yet his fighter jet
crashed during a routine training flight
near Nellis Air Force Base it marks the
third crash for the Thunderbirds in less
than two years and the third military
aircraft to crash in the past two days
on Tuesday a Marine Corps Super Stallion
helicopter crashed in southern
California killing four Marines earlier
that day in East in the East African
nation of Djibouti a marine Harrier jet
crashed on takeoff the pilot ejected and
was released from the hospital but today
the Djibouti government grounded all US
military flights including drones from
the largest American base in Africa
hindering counterterrorism operations
there have been five non combat aviation
crashes this year alone killing nine
service members thirty-seven were killed
in air crashes last year nearly double
the number killed in 2016 but a top
general at the Pentagon would not call
it a crisis I would reject wave in
crisis
those are mishaps that occurred we're
gonna look at each one in turn each one
is tragic we regret each one we'll look
at them carefully I'm certainly not
prepared to say that it's a wave of
mishaps or of some form of crisis the
House Armed Services Chairman Mac
Thornberry warned the White House not to
rob the military's readiness money to
fund the National Guard at the border
when President George W Bush sent six
thousand troops to the Mexico border it
cost four hundred and fifteen million
dollars money that was stripped from the
Air Force and Navy's operations and
maintenance budgets the Pentagon just
received 700 billion dollars a sizeable
portion of that is supposed to help fix
aircraft and improve pilot training read
Jennifer Griffin at the Pentagon
Jennifer thank you